in the shadow of the steel works a party
is underway
for command's community it's a chance to
raise a
toast but also reflect on what the
monarchy and specifically the role of
prince of wales means to those living
here i am a royalist
i think he has a role
um but we don't relate as much to him as
we do to them
to the queen i think the majority of
people in wales do agree with the
monarchy i think he should be the last
prince of wales as much as we respect
him he hasn't done that much for wales
as a country you know he's uh he very
much represents great britain so i think
it's about time that we had somebody to
represent the country of wales in wales
the royal title of the prince of wales
dates back to england conquering the
nation in the 13th century nowadays
while more symbolic some experts believe
attitudes to the title are changing if
we look back to say the victorian period
onwards there has been a huge pride
within wales that the heir to the throne
was the prince of wales because it was
seen as something that made wales
important
as we move forward in time and kind of
welsh nationalism has grown
um that kind of pride in it has ebbed
away somewhat it's become more
controversial a recent poll by cardiff
university found 55 percent of people in
wales support having a monarchy while 28
would rather have an elected head of
state
while it is of course a weekend of
celebrations the queen's milestone puts
into focus the role of the royal family
here in wales and for younger
generations just what the future of the
monarchy means to them
so who do you prefer charles or william
and kate
williams and why is that
because we both got williams in our
class
because
and they've got kids
and
they're like
really kind
i think perhaps the people's popular
choice would be william and kate because
they are younger perhaps we can relate
to them more they have young children
how important it is to wales
i think it is really important actually
yeah i think it is part of the sort of
welsh identity
happy jubilee
the image of the royals differs between
the generations
while there is support many feel the
monarchy's role in wales may need to
reform in the years to come
and whitehead sky news in port albert
south wales